[Musique]
ouais parce qu'en fait je l'étais
visiter nos une grotte ornée il n'ya pas
longtemps la grotte dans laquelle tu
peux trouver le plus de mains négatives
contre comme ça c'est une ville ouest
est et ça m'a fasciné de voir qu'on fait
donc c'est pas vraiment à quoi ça
servait il ya un coin où les gens
habitent s'il ya un autre ou non c'est
pas ça pourrait des rituels et tout donc
c'est ce à quoi les grottes ornées en
fait la grotte c'est pas on sait pas un
environnement qui est hyper confortable
pour une vie à long terme donc les
campements majoritaire sont des
campagnes plutôt extérieur ou alors en
abris sous roche mais pas réellement
grottes profondes parce que tu as un
fort taux d'humidité et très honnêtement
c'est pas très agréable surtout qu'en
plus tu doit cohabiter généralement avec
des bêtes à l'époque des lion des
cavernes des ours des tigres et c'est
donc c'est pas forcément l'endroit le
plus le plus chaleureux si tu veux mais
effectivement de temps en temps il y
allait de manière ponctuelle pour des
séjours un petit peu court
et puis surtout ils ont là-bas des
activités rituelles assez
exceptionnel par exemple dans la grotte
de bruniquel dans la salle du fond les
mets en der tallien ont coupé les
stalactites et les ondes disposés en
cercle donc tu as un énorme cercle de
150 mètres de diamètre est dedans tu as
des plus petits cercles de stalactites
avec des foyers qui ont été aménagés ça
ne sert absolument à rien enfin tu vois
si tu veux
enfin on trouve pas de voie là se trouve
un jour où on sera quand c'est ça on en
trouve à un usage
messages quotidiens as et du bon usage
technique probablement que pour se
donner autant de mal ça devait servir à
quelque chose dans leur tête joie mais
c'était peut-être une efficacité du coup
qu'on estime une efficacité rituel
pareil pour les peintures c'est vraiment
des choses qui sont très chronophage
mais un investissement de tank est
absolument énorme en investissements
techniques aussi parce que dans la
grotte de lascaux par exemple tu as des
petits aménagements dans les murs qui
montre que les mecs ont quand même fait
des échafaudages pour aller peindre dans
les parties les plus hautes normes et
donc c'est beaucoup de temps c'est
beaucoup d'énergie c'est des matériaux
qui sont pas forcément locaux faut aller
chercher les autres c'est vrai et donc
c'est forcément quelque chose qui pour
eux qu'on tête et qui avait un sens
après on a forcément un petit peu de mal
à comprendre de quoi il s'agissait mais
en tout cas pour le groupe c'était un
investissement important moi j'admire
beaucoup les archéologues parce qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de deux choses qu'il
faut ici est déterminé d'après des
indices et tout ça paraît tellement
casse comme ça juste pour revenir si
cette histoire de stalactites là ça me
fait marrer parce que justement dans la
grotte qu'on a visités en fait toutes
les stalactites et stalagmites été
coupée parce que la grotte se fait
visiter depuis le 19e siècle entre comme
ça et les guides à l'époque il coupait
des stalactites pour les files aux
visiteurs quoi en mode souvenirs à
devenir montlhéry chouette non
j'imagine que c'était la meilleure chose
bah oui
du coup il y avait plus grand chose en a
d'autres mais dit non alors on est un
peu dans le pays des autres moi je
reviens sur les axes après des trucs un
petit peu un petit peu fun à me raconter
sur ce matériel très particulier pour la
triste cessé d oxyde de fer c'est des
terres avec des oxydes de fer dedans et
le truc c'est que bourg prouvant si on a
quand même pas mal ça sert effectivement
à plein de choses il ya plein de par un
tri sont venus s'installer ici tous à
sézanne cap 1 1 milliard de fois la
sainte victoire qui est au-dessus
d'aix-en-provence tout ça ce qui est
marrant dans les autres quand même c'est
que parce que nous on préhistoire il
utilise de l'encré rouge - mais parfois
aussi de locre jaune et de manière
extrêmement ponctuels c'est un petit peu
plus rares on en trouve moi en france
mais on est aussi de l'offre carrément
violette donc c'est bizarre quand même
que cette palette de couleurs pour
finalement un même phénomène géologique
ça s'est fait comme en bas ça dépend de
la composition était hors tout
simplement parce que tu peux avoir je
pense que les truites violer et de les
voir le manganèse ou l'aluminium des
dents ou des trucs comme ça et puis
sinon il ya tout ça il ya le faire
ferrer qui est le faire chez eux donc f2
+73 plus ces trucs là et ça ça fait des
mêmes en chimie tu peux faire des
précipité de fer ferrique et ferron pas
la même couleur et du coup sur les sols
aussi ça influera sur la couleur de tout
ça c'est une histoire de composition
chimique dans le genre robe violette 6 à
la bauxite qui est pas loin d'ici et ça
à mon avis c'est parce qu'il y aurait de
l'aluminium dedans parce que
donc si c'est bien de la bauxite
effectivement c'est un minerai
d'aluminium qui a été extrait en
carrière depuis permettant à tous et qui
a été décrit pour la première fois aux
baux de provence juste à côté d'ici mais
c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle la
bauxite
je ne bois l'anecdote ce
que je
sais moi je trouve ça fait rire
[Musique]
oh